lebanon's economic crisis is heading
into its fourth year
the state is nearly bankrupt
it can't buy fuel for electricity
infrastructure is falling apart
while institutions struggle to afford
basic operating costs
there's a desperate need for hard
currency the International Community
made clear any funding will only come
from the international monetary fund
that means reforming a dysfunctional
system blamed on Decades of
mismanagement and Corruption
but there hasn't been political will
the ruling Elites doesn't want these
reforms because it will undermine the
structure of their power that has been
going on for for 30 years now
the country's leaders have refused to
open the books at the central bank they
failed to pass laws to investigate all
Financial crimes and stop billions of
dollars being transferred abroad
instead the shared interests of the
political and financial Elite have led
to bank customers suffering losses and
being denied access to their savings
program between the IMF and Lebanon
would involve passing structural reforms
and anti-corruption measures to improve
governance that's likely to hurt the
interests of politicians accused of
using the state for the interest of
themselves and their Associates
this was once a middle-income country
but the local currency has lost value
and its Financial losses are estimated
to amount to 72 billion dollars that is
four times the size of the economy
officials say they remain committed to
the path laid out by the IMF but there's
still no consensus on a recovery plan
major reforms normally economical wise
can't go on with any
unnormal circumstance as in Lebanon we
need stability on the political level
all the while one of the world's worst
meltdowns deepens by the day
Beirut